okay hello everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others it happens to be a
holiday in the u.s for at least for our
company um so we have a slightly
different group
helping me here today so
everything will go great all right we
have a whole bunch of questions that
were
left over from last time so many
interesting things
all right there was a question here from
deepa uh what is
dark matter okay
so out in the universe
we see lots of stars and other things
which are
not dark they're bright they are things
where they're generating light
we can tell they're there because we can
see that they're stars that are
producing uh energy and light and so on
but we can try and deduce how much stuff
there is in the universe
by looking at the gravitational effects
of
the things that are out there so for
example when we have a star like the sun
it has planets that are orbiting around
it that are held in their orbits by the
force of gravity
from the sun but the question is are
there
dark objects out there in the universe
or dark
things out there in the universe that
are producing gravity
but which we don't detect by seeing them
producing light
things perhaps like stars or maybe it's
made of something quite different
which can have a gravitational effect
without
being something that we can tell is
there from the fact that it's producing
light and so on
so people observed from a long time ago
that if you look at
galaxies so our galaxy is an example of
a big spiral galaxy
spiral it's called the spiral galaxy
it's basically a flat pancake of stars
about 100 billion stars
that are in the sort of flat pancake um
that are rotating around the center
it's a little bit like the planets
rotating around the sun the planets are
more or less in one plane they're more
or less in the plane of the ecliptic
they're just they form this kind of disc
around the sun
made of the ordinary planets and then
there are the asteroids the minor
planets and so on also there
it's this kind of flat disc well
similarly our galaxy
is sort of a flat disc of stars rotating
around the center
we now know at the center of our galaxy
actually there's a big black hole
but that's not so relevant it still will
be the case that
a galaxy we can expect the galaxy of our
sort of size
is going to be this big flat collection
of stars all rotating around
okay so then you ask the question can
you explain
the rotation rates of the outer stars as
it's rotating around
based on the amount of mass that you can
see
in in in inside the galaxy so to speak
and the thing that was observed first i
don't know probably
40 years ago 50 years ago maybe more
than that
is that the rotation curves of galaxies
which means
the the kind of the the sort of the
period of rotation
um uh as uh of of outer things and so on
the speed of rotation of outer things
could that all be explained on the basis
of the amount of
mass that we could see existed in stars
in the interior of our galaxy and the
answer was no it didn't quite work
and so that was a little mysterious but
people thought oh it's something to do
with the way galactic
dynamics worked and so on people got
more and more confused and there was
really strange examples like there are
galaxies that are colliding with each
other
where it seems that there's something
that's attracting pieces of these
galaxies even though you don't see it in
terms of stars
so then the question is okay what is
this dark stuff in the universe
that is not um
that doesn't show up as as things like
stars
and you know is it in fact correct that
there's so much dark stuff in the
universe
it's not been completely clear so there
are several possibilities it could be
that the estimate that there's dark
stuff in the universe comes about
because one's using
a standard theory of gravity and maybe
that theory of gravity isn't quite right
because once deducing that there's the
stark stuff by looking at its
gravitational effect
but maybe if the theory of gravity isn't
quite right then that deduction isn't
quite right
but it seems like that's not the right
explanation
so the question of what dark matter
actually is well nobody knows
so it's possible it could be something
very big like big
like little black holes or planet-like
things or something
that seems somewhat unlikely because you
would tend to see if it was big things
if one of them went in front of a star
for example
you would see the light of the star be
dimmed from where we're looking at it
so the possibility then is that maybe
it's a small kind of particle maybe it's
some
some kind of particle that is uh that
doesn't interact much with ordinary
matter
um but which nevertheless has a
gravitational effect that does have a
mass
but it doesn't have like an electric
charge or any other thing that makes it
interact strongly with mata
and that's kind of most people's belief
about what the most likely
candidate for what dark matter is and
there are lots of searches
that people try to do of looking for
these very
slight interactions between dark matter
and ordinary matter
in in our theory of physics there's a
possibility that there are particles
that are much much lighter than
electrons for example
maybe uh a um a
as much as uh a uh a billion trillion
times
lighter than electrons um and those
that are that are the result of of sort
of very
small perturbations in the structure of
space-time um
uh much smaller than the ones that lead
to things like electrons
and that's a possibility for what this
dark matter could be
now one of the confounding uh strange
effects is that
dark matter produces gravity and so
when you have lots of gravity it tends
to make things
sort of uh be attracted inward
but the universe is expanding and
one of the things that's happened last
by 20 years is a lot of detailed
measurements of the rate of expansion of
the universe
that's a tricky thing to figure out you
know how fast is the universe expanding
well it depends
how far away things are in the universe
and then you have to have
some way of of knowing that there's sort
of a standard candle
a thing which is always the same
brightness however far away from you it
is
and however old the light that came from
it is
and so there are things people try to do
in terms of supernovas
explosions of stars and the brightness
of those and so on but there are a bunch
of experiments now
that give one some decent estimates of
kind of
uh how fast the universe is expanding
and one of the things that's that's very
strange
is there seems to be some potential
acceleration in the expansion of the
universe
but dark matter like ordinary matter
just has a gravitational effect it just
makes things it just
makes things uh pulls things together so
it will tend to make the universe
slow down in its expansion rather than
speed up in its expansion
and so any positive mass object will
basically make the universe
will tend to pull things together and
reduce the rate of expansion
so in order to have something which
accelerates the rate of expansion
the way one would do that within the
context of standard theories of gravity
and so on
is to have something with negative mass
and so then
they came along this idea of what's
called dark energy which is essentially
negative mass
stuff that is supposed to be something
that can accelerate the rate of
expansion in the universe
now if one's sort of an observer of
scientific theories
one could start getting a bit skeptical
at this point it's like well
they're these things that were attracted
more than you expected and so you
invented dark
matter oh well they're these things that
are that are sort of anti-attracted
repelled more than you expect
so you ex you invent dark energy you're
kind of piling up these various
hypotheses
and that seems a little unconvincing we
don't know how this will come out
in in our theory of physics uh
we don't yet have enough precision
in our ways of predicting what happens
in cosmology
to be able to say anything terribly
definitive about this but i think
there's the chance that we'll be able to
see how this works in
in that theory so there's a question
here
from uh motu um
what is the fabric of space-time
what gives rise to it what is it made of
okay
well you kind of came to the right place
to ask that question
so what people believed for the last
hundred years or so
is that well okay the question one
question is what is space
right so so usually when people think
about space
they think about it as just a place
where you put stuff
it isn't anything in particular it's
just a place a place where you put stuff
so
like you're doing euclidean geometry
you're just putting down
points in the plane let's say the plane
exists already
it's just a background you say i'm going
to put this point at this position i'm
going to put this other point at this
position
i can say what the distance between them
is i can have all these discussions and
so on
but space itself isn't anything it's
just something that i can use to put
things in
okay so one of the things that sort of a
big idea of our
new theory of physics is that space
actually isn't just a place where you
put things
it's something that's made of something
itself
so what does that what does that mean
well the idea is that space
instead of that all these points that
you can put down in space
they actually they're the space is just
made of a whole collection of points
and there are particular points that
exist in space it's not just
you can pick any position it's there
that the space is made from a whole
collection of discrete points
and those points don't have any
particular position at first
the only thing one can say about those
points is how they're connected to each
other so it's kind of a giant network
think about it like a friend network for
example
they're all these friends you don't
necessarily know where they live
geographically you just know this person
is friends with these three other people
this person's friends with these three
other people and so on
and that's how we think it works for
points in space
that the points in space don't that it's
not like we know geographically where
they're placed
we just know which points are connected
to which other points
so you might be able to say well if we
know the whole friend network we can
kind of guess
the effective geography because the
people who are
a kind of uh there's this whole cluster
of people who all know each other
they're probably nearby and they're far
away from people who are
who you have to go through many steps of
you know friend to friend to friend
to get to that other person and that's
kind of our theory of the structure of
space
is that the structure of space is this
giant kind of network
in which the the individual pieces are
kind of like atoms of space
they're the they're the kind of discrete
uh
uh un indivisible points that exist
in in space but those points
are each separate kinds of points give
you an analogy
so you go back 150 years people would
look at a fluid like water
liquid like water and they'd say water's
just a continuous thing
so if you imagine you know can you if
you were to
put something somewhere in that water
you were to attach something to a piece
of water
you could say well i can put my thing i
can put my marker
absolutely anywhere i want in this water
because just this continuous fluid
turns out that won't be true because the
water is actually made of discrete
molecules
and to attach something to a piece of
water in the end
you're attaching it to an individual
molecule you can't you know there's
spaces between the molecules where
there's nothing there
you can't attach it to that if you want
to attach something
to a piece of water you're ultimately
attaching it to a molecule
and so it is i think with space that in
a sense there's nothing
in space except these atoms of space and
unlike in the case of water where we
know the absolute sort of positions of
different molecules relative to each
other
in space all we know is sort of the
friendship of points
we just know the connectivity of these
points in space
so that that's kind of the what we think
the structure of space is
now question is what what happens to
space
and the idea is that at every moment
there are little groups of these sort of
atoms of space that have these little
patterns of connections
and whenever the pattern looks like
something whenever it has a particular
wave a is connected to b is connected to
c is connected to a et cetera et cetera
so particular arrangement
then there is a transformation that can
be made
from that arrangement to another
arrangement so at every moment
these kind of pieces of space are
getting rewritten according to these
rules
now it's a very weird thing because in a
sense
space you know we imagine
that as we go through time that there is
some permanence to us
where you know our i can pick some
object up
and it just it's it exists but in this
model
of of the universe it is being recreated
at every moment in time
the fact that there is a coherence to
the existence of the object through time
is similar to the way that you know if
you have a i don't know a wave in water
for example
there is some notion of of there is a
definite wave and it propagates across
the surface of the water
but the wave is propagating across the
surface of the water but the individual
pieces of water the individual molecules
of water are like just going in circles
in one place it's just the collective
effect
of all those molecules that gives one
this notion of a
a wave that kind of persists and goes
across the water
and so it is similarly i think with the
with the existence of objects
they are continuously recreated at every
moment in time
um because the structure of space is
just this network
and in fact the um uh to make it even
more slightly complicated
the the fact that this network is kind
of knitted together that these different
parts of space are related
is a consequence of the fact that there
are these rewrites happening that there
are these
pieces of space that are that are being
sort of uh
that are being rewritten uh that they
use each other to be rewritten that
in other words you can't do a rewrite
until you have multiple atoms of space
that can kind of cooperate to do this
rewrite and it's that process
of things sort of uh being rewritten
and and connected with each other
through these rewrites that kind of
knits the structure of space
together so in that kind of picture time
is this progressive rewriting of the
network and
space is kind of the extent of the
network
and you kind of can go from one part of
the network to the fact that the network
is kind of
knitted together as a consequence of the
fact that all these little pieces
are involved in these rewrite events
so that's kind of the the small scale
structure of space
and time when you look at it on a large
scale
it's just like what happens in water
there are a bunch of molecules bouncing
around
and they bounce around in very random
ways if you looked under
we don't actually have microscopes
powerful and do this for water but if we
if we look uh if we could imagine seeing
all these molecules bouncing around
they're bouncing around in all these
random ways it's pretty complicated but
on a large scale
the water just seems like it's some
fluid that's flowing
in some way that's pretty easy to
describe and so it is i think with space
that even though these atoms of space
are doing all these very complicated
things on a very small scale
when it comes to the scale on which we
are used to perceiving space
space appears nice and uniform and we
can just say we put things
pretty much anywhere we can pick in
space at the scale we're dealing with it
the actual scale of the sort of in a
sense the effective distance between
atoms of space
might be i don't know 10 to the minus
100 meters
in other words that's a you know a
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion from
a meter
so it's a very very small distance it's
uh it's very tiny
for example a a proton is
um about a thousand trillionth of a
meter across
so this elementary length in space is
really really really tiny
compared to the kinds of objects that we
that we know about
so anyway that's that's sort of a
picture of what what space might be made
of
now on a large scale space we can think
about
space as being this kind of uh people
talk about the fabric of space-time
um that's kind of the notion that there
is
a a way of thinking about space-time as
sort of a continuous
thing and the structure of space-time is
affected in particular
by the presence of massive objects in in
space
so this is sort of the the classic fact
about general relativity einstein's
theory of gravity from 1915
the uh the okay so the the basic idea
is what's a straight line well we're
used to the idea if we
have a piece of paper it's a flat thing
we make uh we
put down two points we say what's the
shortest
path between these two points oh it's a
straight line
okay now we put those points on the
surface of a sphere
we say what is what's the shortest path
between those two points
well it's a curved path the great circle
path on the sphere
looked at from the outside it's not a
straight line it's a line that's curved
on the surface of the sphere
and we can as we look at different kinds
of surfaces
we can say well the the shortest path
is something which at least looked at
from the outside doesn't look like a
straight line
although sort of within the surface it
is the straight line of the surface the
shortest path between two points
okay so then the idea is that
the structure of space as it exists in
the universe
is distorted by the presence of mass so
when there's a star
sitting there in space it's essentially
deforming
the very structure of space and that
means that what what counted as a
straight line what was a
an ordinary straight line now the
straight lines are actually things which
looked at from the outside are curved
and they're curved in just such a way
that if you were to say
oh i should have said something else
which is the the when there are no
forces acting
on something then you expect it to just
go in a straight line
and for example you know you you shoot a
laser somewhere
you'll see the laser just makes a
straight line of light
and but the question is who's straight
line so to speak
and the whole point is that in the
presence of mass what general relativity
says
is that the presence of mass leads to a
distortion in the structure of space
that
is such that the straight lines in that
distorted space correspond to curved
parts when looked at from the outside
and the curvature of those pars is
exactly what you would expect
from the idea that there's a sort of
force of gravity associated with that
mass
so in our models of physics the way that
works is
energy and mass are associated
essentially with the density of activity
in the network
and it then turns out that it's a purely
mathematical fact
that in our in the structure of our
systems that
the the the sort of shortest paths
are when there is lots of activity in
the network
it will essentially distort the
effective structure of space that's
produced by the
effect of all of these different
connections in the network in just such
a way
that it will distort the paths um
in uh as a result of the presence of
energy
or the presence of mass which is sort of
an equivalent kind of thing and
the mathematical structure of that
distortion
turns out to be exactly what
generalizability says it should be
and that's sort of exciting to us
because it means that from something
much lower level
from just talking about atoms of space
and connections between atoms of space
and rewritings of atoms of space and so
on that we're reproducing
kind of the the things that have been
well investigated experimentally
in the theory of gravity and in general
ultimately so that's sort of been
exciting to us
but i think it's interesting to kind of
see uh
you know one can ask the question how
come there's anything that sort of
permanently exists through time in the
universe all these little microscopic
atoms of space they're all getting
rearranged
et cetera et cetera et cetera what is it
that persists
well it's a little bit we can again use
an analogy of a fluid
if you've got some water and you make a
vortex a whirlpool
type thing it's just sort of going
around in the water you can easily do
that if you run your finger through some
water
you'll see there's a whole street of
vortices that get produced behind your
finger if you run it reasonably slowly
through water you can see that
um those vortices are kind of little
little swirls in the water
and they have the property that they
will tend to be quite persistent
but you can't sort of get rid of that
swirl without kind of
slowing the whole thing down that the
swirl there's no continuous way to get
rid of
the thing that that is this kind of uh
so-called topologically stable it's got
this kind of hole in
the middle so to speak because it's kind
of going round um
going around that center point so that's
a that's a sort of
a stable thing in this fluid in the case
of water
so what we imagine is that there are
similar kinds of things
in the structure of of space that there
are similar kinds of
sort of knotted vortex like things
that's a bad description of them we are
beginning to have better
kind of very fancy mathematical
descriptions of what's going on there
but that there are essentially things
which are persistent
in the structure even though the
individual atoms of space
are different atoms of space over time
the the structure
remains the same it's like the water
wave i mentioned earlier it's like these
vortices
even though the particular molecules of
water involved in that vortex
may change the structure of the vortex
remains the same and so it is
with uh with structures in space and
that's kind of why there's a persistence
to um that we think that's sort of why
there's persistence to anything in the
universe why it's consistent from one
moment why it appears consistent from
one moment to the next
is because there are these uh sort of
persistent objects that are produced
by kind of the collective effect of many
sort of atoms of space
it's kind of a non-trivial thing because
it's a very weird thing to think that we
are
continually being rewritten there's you
know what is
what are we what are we made of well
it's just like you know the individual
i don't know you know as biological
organisms the individual pieces of our
bones or whatever else are gradually
being sort of broken down and the new
pieces of bone are being formed there
and so on
there's there's a lot of us that is
turning over regularly as one
one you know set of cells die and
another one is produced but
we still remain sort of the same
organism so to speak
uh throughout our lives even though the
individual components that we have
are being changed it's like there's an
old sort of philosophical
uh discussion people have it's usually
talked about in terms of the
the ship of theseus theseus had this
ship it's made of wood it's got a bunch
of planks in it
um it is the ship of theseus but
gradually over time planks wear out
people replace one plank then another
and eventually every plank in the ship
has been replaced
but yet it is still the same ship in
some sense even though its components
have been replaced
but so we think what happens in space is
something much more extreme than that
it's that every at every moment in time
essentially every atom of space that
we're made of is
is changing yet there is a persistence
to our identity through time
and actually another thing that i
realized only very recently in fact
is that when we move in space
it's the same kind of thing it's not
obvious that there should be an idea of
what one would
call pure motion that one should be able
to take a thing
and move it in space it could be the
case and as we move it
it's again it's it's make being made up
of different atoms of space as we move
it
um but the the thing the fact that there
is a persistent existence
to that object as we move it even though
the underlying atoms of space from which
it's made of changing
that's a sort of non-trivial fact about
the world
that it's possible to have what one
might call pure motion or one's just
moving things around
without them changing their character as
you move them
i noticed there was another question
here about is there something smaller
than quarks from c
plus plus um that's very related to what
i'm talking about here
the uh
in if we look at you know
physical atoms are made of atomic nuclei
and electrons
the atomic nuclei are made of protons
and neutrons the protons neutrons are
made of quarks and gluons
um what's below quarks you can also ask
what's below electrons
the answer is so far nobody knows so far
as people can tell
right now electrons are like point
particles they're exact precise
geometrical points
same same with quarks it's a little bit
complicated in quantum field theory
because these particles are always
interacting with other particles
and so there's kind of a cloud of other
particles around the thing
but the core electron i'm just an
electron nothing but an electron which
by the way
you can't ever get in quantum field
theory because there's always this kind
of uh
uncertainty principle cloud of other
things around it but but
in some at least conceptual sense
there's a pure
bare electron and it's a point particle
as far as current
physics is concerned it has no extent
we know it's smaller than um uh let's
see it's
smaller than a millionth the size of a
proton
uh that's that's the limit from
experiments
on the size of an electron size of a
quark i guess that's
pretty much the same limits about the
millionth the size of a
photon so a core a proton might be made
of three primary quarks and a bunch of
extra
extra quarks and gluons around it but um
those individual quarks that's made over
might be a millionth the size of um
uh of the of the proton are less than a
millionth the size of the proton
uh it's a bit similar to in an atom that
the complete size of an atom
is about uh um uh one tenth of a billion
of a billionth of a meter um and that's
um that's about
uh a hundred thousand times bigger than
the atomic nucleus
so that the size of the whole atom is
about a hundred thousand times bigger
than the size of the nuclear atomic
nucleus in the center uh the quarks that
are within
the protons and things within the atomic
nucleus we know at least less than a
millionth the size of
of the of the protons and so on now
you know what's inside all those things
well in our theory of physics
we actually have something to say about
that what's inside
is a whole complicated tangle of atoms
of space
which as i've mentioned there is some
kind of uh
topological stability there is some kind
of structure like vortices in water and
things like that
which is persistent and that's what
leads to things like quarks and so on
and um it's not obvious
that uh exactly which kinds of you know
vortices or whatever they are
which kinds of particles exist we don't
know yet
they have a few ideas for how that might
come out of our models
um but there's a a particular set there
are six kinds of quarks that exist
there are six kinds of leptons which is
what the electron is an example of
that exists there are three kinds of
things that are like electrons electrons
which have a mass
of about um uh um one
thousandth one two thousandth of the
mass of a proton
then there's a thing called the muon
which has a mass of about a tenth the
mass of
of a proton and there are things called
tau leptons which have a mass of about
1.5 times
the mass of a proton and nobody knows
why these three different things the
electron the mu and the tau lepton
they all seem like they're the same kind
of thing they just differ in being
having different masses
and it's the same with the quarks there
are these uh
two there's six quarks broken into two
categories
the uh the the up cork the charm cork
the top quark
and the down quark the strange cork the
bottom quark
um and nobody knows why there are these
collection of these three
families of quarks three families of
leptons
perhaps we will have an explanation of
that in our physics project we don't
know yet
um but uh if you ask the question in our
kind of model of of
physics what are what is an electron
made of well it's ultimately made of
these atoms of space it's some kind of
structure
made up from these atoms of space one
thing that's kind of a
weird point is that if you just say in
our models one of the features of them
is there's nothing in the universe
except
space electrons are just some
complicated tangle in the structure of
space
everything else you know black holes are
also just some big
tangle in the structure of space not
quite the same kind of tangle
they just have a a certain structure
with respect to
the the uh the form of these connections
between the atoms of space
so one of the things that i i'm thinking
is probably going to be true
is that in some sense black holes are
the same kind of thing as particles like
electrons
and so in some very rough kind of sense
it won't be precisely like this
but you know electrons are a little bit
like very very tiny black holes
they're a little bit like a funkiness in
the structure of space
just as black holes are that electrons
are kind of a very small version of that
so when you start asking questions about
what's
uh you know what's inside quarks well
what's inside quarks is this tangle and
structure of space
and um uh whether whether you can say
well
well i can make out of that something
which is a particle a persistent kind of
particle-like thing
probably not but it's not clear i mean
that that's a
that's a question for example are there
more generations of quarks
we pretty much know that there aren't we
pretty much know that three is it
actually
in when i was much younger this is uh
when was it 1979 or so
um with a friend of mine
who subsequently won a nobel prize in
physics actually
um chap called david pollitzer um we uh
we wrote this paper uh where we kind of
tried to work out in the kind of
standard model of particle physics
what would happen if there were much
more massive hawks
and leptons what would what would happen
to the structure of models of physics if
that was the case
and what we could see was with the
standard kind of setup of models of
physics
these are models of physics that are not
nearly as kind of foundational as the
models that i'm dealing with now
um but with the sort of standard models
of physics that
have been developed over the past i
don't know what was it then about 70
years or something now it's more like
100 and something years
um the uh those um
those models their consistency
requires that they're not be quarks and
leptons that are much heavier
than for example the top walk that's
been observed
uh what happens is it's a take a little
bit of explanation to go through this
and perhaps it's not worth it but
but what basically happens is the thing
that leads to the
the these particles having a mass that
mechanism the so-called higgs mechanism
kind of self-destructs if the amount of
mass it has to put into
individual particles is too large it
self-destructs because
the kind of the quantum corrections to
the
the the way that it gives mass end up
being bigger than
the the other features of it and
essentially the whole universe becomes
unstable
so at least in the in the sort of
traditional models of physics
it's not likely there are any more
generations of quarks and leptons
because it would lead to instability in
those in those standard models of
physics
um exactly how that will work in our
model of physics
sort of lower level model of physics we
don't yet know and that's a sort of an
interesting uh
question that is um uh going forward
so um
let's see there were a whole bunch of
questions here oh my gosh
um i'm going to pick a few at random
here so there's a question from
just here how do black holes appear
sort of continuously going from zero
topological holes to one
okay a black hole
ah that's a complicated question hmm
okay um
okay in ordinary in the ordinary theory
of general relativity in the ordinary
theory of gravity
space-time is a continuum that means
that it's sort of a continuous
fabric in a sense you could make it if
it was it's actually
three plus one-dimensional roughly but
if it was if it was two-dimensional you
could make it out of this sort of uh
actual piece of fabric a rubber sheet or
something like this
and the the mathematical theory is such
that you can distort the rubber sheet
however you want
but you can never tear it you can never
break a piece off you can never make a
hole in it
etc etc etc it's always a continuous
rubber sheet
it is just undergoing certain
deformations
okay so that's the standard theory of
general relativity as as albert einstein
you know defined it in 1915 um
it just distorts the rubber sheet okay
in our theory of physics
things get a bit more subtle because it
isn't just this continuous rubber sheet
the rubber sheet is in a sense made of
this network of atoms of space
and it's no longer the case in in the
standard theory of relativity
there's no way to tear the rubber sheet
in our model with networks and so on
it isn't true anymore that there's no
way to kind of make tears
and make discontinuities in the
structure of space you can go from
something
in a sense it's always got this
discontinuous discrete structure
so the fact that something opens up or a
piece breaks off and so on
it's not a dramatic oh you have to take
a knife to the fabric of space
it's just something that can happen
because a bunch of the edges
that um the the connections that join
one piece of space to another
all those connections sort of get
reformed and they aren't there anymore
and so a piece breaks off
so in our models it is possible to have
for example pieces of space break off
it's possible to have a change of
topology in space
it's possible to have those things
happen as a dynamical process
that's not possible in general
relativity however
there's a bit of a clue in general
relativity so in a black hole
there is what happens is you solve the
equations of general relativity
and they tell you things about the
structure of space-time and they tell
you in the simplest case of non-rotating
black holes
they tell you something that is a bit
embarrassing
they say at the center of a black hole
there is an infinite curvature
this fabric of space is infinitely
curved in fact that infinite curvature
is such that there's this place where
the equations that you thought you used
to describe the fabric of space
can't apply there's a singularity in
space-time
and so you have to say well i thought i
had this equip these equations that
describe the whole of space
but actually whoops somehow at the
center of this black hole
there is this place where there's a
singularity and my equations don't apply
so now you have to kind of tiptoe around
that thinking about well how do you form
a black hole
how do you form that singularity it is a
mathematical inevitability
that there will be such a singularity
but if you say
show me equations the actual moment of
formation of that singularity
that's not something you can do now the
equations sort of escape that to some
extent
because one of the weird things that
happens in black holes is that time
stops and that means that if you are
going towards the singularity at the
center of a black hole
you in a sense you are you will
you can think of it as it never gets
there for you you never
you never get to it because you kind of
you are
you're thinking time is passing time is
passing time is passing but actually
from an observer outside time has
stopped and so
you never get to the point where you
actually reach that singularity because
for you
time has stopped um and so it's kind of
like the analogy of the
you know the the the computer that's
that's
in there the ai that's in there and the
ai
effectively somebody sort of pulls the
plug of the ai
and it just stops thinking it's
effectively you know it's a
it's a dying ai it doesn't it it's
thought processes
grind to a halt and so it doesn't know
that it never actually got you know
never it never knows what happens when
it got to the singularity
because it's not thinking at that point
it's it's its thought processes have
stopped
time has stopped for it so so that's
some so in in the standard theory of
general activity
the um uh there is this embarrassing
point
that you never really see the
singularity you never you can never
really describe how that singularity
forms
doesn't the case in our models in fact
we can explicitly see that
we've done actual simulations of the
formation of singularities and so on
and very wonderful things happen a very
bizarre thing that happens with spinning
black holes
is that in the standard theory of
relativity
um you there's sort of weird weird
things that happen it's black holes spin
faster than some critical critical speed
and um
in our models we can see weird things
happening and the weird thing that
happens is a piece of the universe
breaks off
if there is a supercritical black hole
that piece of the universe literally
detaches
it's like a separate detached piece of
space-time
that can never reattach so you better
sort of hope that there are no
supercritical black holes because
they'll just be
there'll be a a kind of a a uh
you know pieces of the universe will be
detaching off there
now there are black holes that have
observed been observed they're very
close to that critical rotation speed
and in fact we suspect that very close
to that critical rotation speed
we will actually see essentially a
microscope that sees
into the sort of gravitational
microscope that allows us to see the
the microscopic structure of space-time
and it's possible that we will even be
able to see
effectively this discrete structure in
space-time and these supercritical black
holes
or black holes close to the critical uh
rotation speed
that essentially pieces of the universe
will be still connected
but hanging by a small number of threads
and the fact that it's a small number of
threads means it becomes possible to see
that it's a
discrete number rather than a giant you
know trillions and trillions and
trillions of these things
so that's a possibility there but that's
um the the uh
the question of how you go from uh kind
of
um uh topologically you know how you
change the topology of space that
something happens in our models
does not happen in standard general
relativity now you know an analogy to
these things
uh that's interesting to see in terms of
particles and so on
is imagine you have a network all kinds
of you know you've got pieces of string
that are connecting
these nodes together and so on imagine
this network is planar
in the sense that you've got all these
pieces of string and that they're
connected to these attachment points
and there's a way of putting down the
attachment points
so that there are no two pieces of
string that have to cross over
so there's a bunch of results in
mathematics there's a thing with a fancy
name of kurotovsky's theorem
that tells you if you're going to have
this network of pieces of string
then there's only if there if they are
not going to be able to be laid out in a
plane just plain early so that nothing
crosses over
there are particular subgraphs
particular local arrangements
of sort of the connections of pieces of
string which force non-polarity
there are just two sort of sort of in a
sense
atoms of non-planarity that can exist
there are two configurations
which if present will lead to
non-planarity and every non-polarity
can be decomposed into these into these
pieces
so in a sense if you then have something
which is rearranging all these pieces of
string
but always keeping them planar then
then you can never generate one of these
pieces of non-planarity
if you have one of these pieces of
non-polarity those kind of
rearrangements that keep things plain it
will never destroy that piece of
nonbinarity
so the thing that happens when you're in
instead of that's a that's an analogy
for particles in our structure of space
uh of the network to represent space
then
there's sort of a a um
[Music]
you know that's that's the analogy is
that these pieces of non-primarity in
this otherwise planar network
and when a particle when let's say two
particles are created
you might be creating two pieces of
non-primarity and that's that's
something that you can do
and and they sort of untangle from each
other and you get these two pieces of
non-planarity which in their local
regions of
of of the of the network um you can't
sort of locally untangle so that's kind
of a little bit of a picture
of how one thinks about particles and so
on
well let's see um
oh gosh so many questions here
uh
all sorts of interesting questions
is there a computational spur to us is
there a computational system
similar to quarks well
if you're asking the question can we
make
a computational system that emulates
what happens with quarks
and what happens with gluons which are
the particles that uh
like the like the photons for
electromagnetism the
the the gluons are like the analogy of
that for
quarks and for what's called color
charge and they're what
they're what are responsible for sort of
holding the quarks and a proton together
uh is there a way that we can make a
sort of computational model of what's
going on there
um i think the answer is yes we haven't
done it yet
but i think our models of the structure
of fundamental physics
will allow us to make essentially a
computational model
of what happens inside quarks and
between quarks and so on
there's been an approach that's been uh
worked on for the last uh 40
or so years called lattice gage theory
and it's a way of
sort of putting on a computer an
emulation of what happens with quarks
and gluons and so on
unfortunately it has a number of weird
mathematical features
probably its weirdest feature is that it
fundamentally has no
notion of time in fact much more
bizarrely
uh what's done is that time usually time
is something somewhat different from
space in our models of physics
time is very different from space but
time is anyway
there's a there's a sort of a different
structure to the to time
than the structure to space and in in
lattice gauge theory it's necessary to
kind of turn
time into something just like space in
the fancy language of physics it's a
thing called the wick rotation
and it basically turns um
time becomes essentially a an additional
you can think of it as an imaginary uh
coordinates version of space
and so it's kind of a weird mathematical
twisting
that has to be done to make this largest
gauge theory thing and then a bunch of
results i got which
sometimes agree with experiment um but
it's it's a little hard to know
how that corresponds because there's no
notion of time so it's not possible to
for example have
a phenomenon like scattering where two
particles come in they collide
they go out again you have to look at
much more indirect versions of the
of what's going on but i think it looks
like with our models we will be able to
get to something which is
a a proper kind of computerized version
of something like what happens in in
theory of quarks and so on the only
problem is
that when we do that simulation we're
doing it on the biggest computers we
might imagine
um but those computers still the uh
the number of sort of atoms of space
that we can
have in one of those computers it might
be a trillion or something you know
in a current computer but that's
unbelievably tiny
compared to the number of atoms in space
that actually might exist
inside a single proton so in other words
the universe is a much
bigger user of computational resources
than
we ever could be with our electronic
computers and so on so the question is
do we get a good approximation to what's
happening inside a proton
by just using a trillion atoms of space
as opposed to a trillion trillion and
showing trillion trillion atoms of space
or something
and the chances are it will be quite a
good approximation that's what we're
finding in the case of gravitation
theory
um so that's an encouraging possibility
for us being able to
reproduce the important effects there uh
computationally
let's see zachary says in our physics
project
say in black hole could it leave a sort
of a wake
in the atoms of space in its past light
cone
ah that's an interesting question hmm
um okay so i think the answer is the
following
the um
the problem is it's like
you run your finger through a piece of
water through some water
the molecules in the water are getting
the
precise you know motions of the
molecules in the water are getting
thrown all over the place by you running
your finger through
but you will not detect those those are
a much too smaller scale for you to be
aware of that
what you can tell is the large scale
motion of the water behind your finger
and i think it's the same kind of thing
in space a black hole goes through space
and it indeed will churn up
the uh the microscopic structure of
space completely
just as sort of anything going through
space will churn up the microscopic
structure of space
but what will happen is a bit similar to
what happens in a fluid
that the large scale behavior will be
indistinguishable from the large scale
behavior you would get
if the thing hadn't been churned up that
way so i i think
it will i'm
i think okay so there is an interesting
effect which i'll describe to you guys
uh which i wonder i wonder could that
possibly happen
well okay let me describe the effect the
the buzz word is
long time tails and uh let me describe
the effect
it was observed in the 1960s to 1970s
um so imagine you have a bunch of
billiard balls and let's say you're
simulating them on a computer and the
billiard balls are bouncing around
and they have they just elastically
bounce off each other every time they
collide they bounce off
and you might say well is that a good
model you know that might be a good
model for molecules in a gas for example
okay so one thing you can do is you can
ask the question if i
if i uh if i like
you know knock one of those billiard
balls if i if i sort of
perturb one of those billiard balls if i
if i poke one of those billiard balls
and then i let the billiard ball kind of
uh then it runs into lots of other
billiard balls which runs lots more
billables and so on
the question is how long will the effect
of that poking of one billiard ball
actually
last because it's the billiard ball is
kind of knocking into other ones which
are knocking into other ones
and you might think that the effect of
just poking that one billiard ball
would quickly decay away you quickly
wouldn't be able to tell
that you'd done that because all these
other billables were randomly bouncing
off each other and so on
and the effect would disappear and
people expected
that that effect would die off
exponentially in the sense that
if you've uh you know if you certain
amount of time
it's it's decreased by some factor you
go twice the time it will decrease by
that factor again so the square of that
factor and so on it will keep going
and it will it will uh decrease
exponentially
in time so to die off very rapidly what
was observed in computer experiments
people didn't know for a long time
they've done the experiments correctly
but it is correct
is that there is what's called a long
time tail there is a
uh it lasts a lot longer than you would
think in in mathematical terms instead
of being exponential decay
as a power law decay um to the the
effect of um i mean the fancy
mathematical terminology
uh i don't usually mention that in these
in these sessions but i i
uh it's the so-called auto correlation
functions
um are uh die off only and
as a power law rather than exponentially
but in any case so there is a
an effect that even these at the very
microscopic level
there is a slight persistence more than
you would expect
to this um uh to you know making a
perturbation in the system
and so the thing that i do wonder about
is a good question
whether there are long time tails now
doesn't mean that they would be
observable because it's long time tails
down at very very very very very tiny
times and very tiny distances and things
but it gives one a little bit more of a
hope that there might be something
absorbable it's a good thing to look at
and i
i will uh i'll think about that some
more thank you for that uh
for that question um
let's see uh
there's a question from riff uh is the
structure i'm not quite sure what that's
referring to probably of electrons
if we knew what electrons were made of
would we be able to
would we be able to duplicate objects
uh no no
and um the the issue of
of let's say that we know that
everything is made of this sort of
structure
of the sort of tangled structure of the
of the structure of this network that
represents space
and let's say we want to make a copy of
one of those
things that is in the structure of space
we're not really given much advantage in
doing that
it's like saying i've got a vortex in
water and i want to make another vortex
how do i do that
and how do i do it using just the water
that's there
there's no real good way to do that in
other words just knowing what the thing
is made of
doesn't allow you to make a a
physicalized copy of it
now we could imagine if we were making a
copy in a computer we were making a
simulation of it
yes absolutely that gives us a big leg
up on doing that
but in terms of making a physical copy
being able to clone things physically
no in fact in in quantum mechanics in
sort of the theory of very microscopic
things which is the theory
that we now finally i'm happy to say i
think actually have a pretty good
understanding of how it really works
there are these things they call the no
cloning theorems
that basically talk about the
impossibility of replicating
quantum states and we can kind of see
pretty explicitly in our models why
those
why those are that way and why it's not
possible to kind of
uh there's a little different than the
question of replicating physical objects
but i think we can see why it is sort of
fundamentally hard
there's no ex we can't expect to have a
procedure for replicating physical
objects
now i have to say we can't expect to
because one of the things that's true
is once you have this kind of underlying
computational structure
that space and everything else is made
of exactly what you can build from that
it's an endless frontier it's just like
if you're given the raw material of a
computer
there's you know the programs you can
build on top of that raw material is an
infinite hierarchy an infinite tower
of ever more sophisticated programs that
you can build just using the hardware of
your computer
and so it will be with the structure of
space and so we don't really know what
the
what the infinite possible technologies
that we could build
from kind of the raw material of
physical space are
um oh my gosh so many things here
uh let's see
um
oh there's a question here which maybe i
shouldn't try and try and address from
uh bhagva is it really possible to get
something from literally nothing
oh boy uh i think i actually figured
that out recently
i didn't think i'd ever figure that out
wasn't clear it was even a question
that any kind of science answer to it
let me give you at least a rough
indication of that and that has to do
with
it's related to the question of why does
the universe exist
uh how can you
why is there something rather than
nothing
so we talk about making models of the
universe we talk about saying
in a computer we can reproduce what the
universe does
but that's a little different from
saying
that that model is actualized as
physical things
in the actual universe or at least it
seems to be a little different
so we might say and somebody was asking
about simulation hypothesis
that's kind of the hypothesis that maybe
we are just a video game
being played by the gods so to speak
um that uh you know that in a sense we
are just
the all of our existence is just like
a program that's running that's being
run by
the gods on their on their uh um
you know on their big video game
simulator so to speak
and so i think that the um
uh so there's this question of of why is
it
that even if we have a model for the
universe which we could simulate on a
computer
um what makes the universe actually be
actualized what makes
that model jump from being purely a
model
to being the actuality of the universe
okay so i didn't think there was ever be
a scientific answer to that question
but i think there is one and it's a i
wonder if i can explain it here
so here's roughly the way to think about
it
so we might think there is a definite
rule for the universe
we run the rule for the universe it
reproduces everything we see in the
universe
but let's imagine instead that we were
running all possible rules for the
universe
all together might think
oh if we're running all possible rules
for the universe how can we ever say
anything about anything
because anything possible can happen
because we've got all these possible
rules and so
it's not the case that that so there's
going to be a rule that does anything
okay so this is the thing to realize
that is a tricky thing
so you have all possible rules
and you start them off in all possible
ways
and two rules you might start off from
from some
state of the universe and then there are
two possible rules you might apply to
that state of the universe
and they lead to two different states of
the universe but then
something else tricky can happen there
might be
two other rules that you can apply which
will take those two different states of
the universe
and turn them into a the same state
so in other words just as you can branch
in this kind of giant network of all
possible states the universe
so you can also merge so something
when you apply all these different rules
you are you are taking a state of the
universe and splitting it into two
different possible states of the
universe
but so also you could take two different
possible states of the universe
and by applying two different rules you
can merge them into the same state
okay so they might say well that's kind
of a trivial effect it's not that
important
actually that effect is unbelievably
critical because that effect
entangles together what happens when you
follow different rules for the universe
it leads to this giant sort of
entanglement
of different possibilities of what
happens when different things when you
apply different rules
to different possible states of the
universe and so the object that you get
by following all possible rules from all
possible states
is this deeply tangled object that is
full of sort of places where
things that you thought were going to
end up with something different end up
with something the same and then they
branch out into something different and
so on
it's a big complicated entangled object
and that entangled object is sort of
a thing that represents the the all
possible theories of physics
in a sense now let's imagine that what's
actually happening in the universe is
it is running all possible theories of
physics that's what the universe
is is something which is running all
possible theories of physics
now the question is how do we perceive
that thing
so remember that we are embedded inside
that whole complicated thing we're part
of this whole thing
that's branching into different uh you
know our brains as we go think about
things they're branching into all the
you know the the actual stuff in our
brains is getting branched into all
these different possible histories and
so on
we are we are part of this giant what we
call rulial multi-way system
of all this sort of following all these
different possible rules and so on
so then the question is let's say we're
part of that how do we actually perceive
what is going on in the universe given
that well this is this is skipping a few
steps ahead
but basically as soon as we assume
that we have coherent identity through
time
as soon as we believe that as soon as we
um
we we construct a way of describing the
universe
in which we have a coherent thread of
experience through time
which is sort of a fundamental feature
of of
consciousness and the way that we
perceive the universe as soon as we
assume that we force certain ways
to look at this sort of complicated uh
universal possible universes
that that assumption in a sense forces
us
to look at only certain slices of this
sort of universal possible universes
and it turns out that the slices that we
look at
necessarily follow the core laws of
physics that we know
so that's a that's a very non-trivial
fact that has come out of our physics
project
that if you start off with sort of the
universal possible universes
and you sample it as an observer inside
that universe
following the same laws as that universe
then inevitably
as soon as you assume certain things so
you imagine certain things about the way
that you are perceiving
what happens in the universe it
necessarily follows
that you will observe the laws of
physics the the main laws of physics
that we know
so in a sense the question of
what what you have to explain then so so
what we're saying is
if we take something which is following
all possible rules
then it is inevitably the case that as
observers embedded within that
we will perceive things which correspond
to what we know to be
standard physics so now the question is
why does this universal possible
universes what does it mean for that to
exist
or not exist or whatever so what you
realize is
that thing is just the working out
of all possible formal facts so for
example one plus one equals two once you
have the definition of one the
definition of plus the definition of two
it is a necessary thing that one plus
one equals two
there's no you can imagine implementing
that by using
stones and counters and so on but one
plus one equals two
is something formally true it does not
depend on any instantiation as anything
so so it is the case that this kind of
um
uh sort of theory of physics that where
you say physics
follows all possible rules in a sense
what it's doing is
every possible formal system is being
there is an instance of every possible
formal system
what this big complicated universal
universe universes is
is the working out of all possible
formal systems which is something that
does not
need to be actualized it is a merely
formal thing because all these systems
like one plus one equals two and so on
they are just
abstract things and the whole point is
that
to an observer who is
part of this whole sort of abstract
object that's being worked out
that observer will perceive exactly what
we know we perceive in terms of the laws
of physics even though
the thing that is there is just this
formal thing that consists of all these
possible formal pieces being worked out
so in a sense what one's saying is it
the
the existence of the universe is no more
than the ex than the fact that formal
things are possible the fact that you
can
imagine writing down one plus one equals
two
it's the aggregate of all those formal
things and it just
turns out that as if you sort of put
yourself in the middle of all of that
you as in a sense will perceive things
which include the laws of physics
so in other words in terms of the
simulation hypothesis where you say
is it are we inside a video game being
played by the gods
well in a sense we're an aside a video
game of all video games
so in other words in a sense all
possible video games are being played
and we are our observation of that
is something which it turns out as a
mathematical derivable fact
corresponds inevitably to something
where we perceive
laws of physics as the laws of physics
turn out to be
so that was that was bit deeply
philosophical i'm sorry that was
but if you ask a question like why does
the universe exist you you can't expect
anything different than something quite
deeply philosophical but anyway
i think the answer i think we actually
have a a pretty good shot at the actual
answer
which is the universe exists because in
a sense all possible formal things
that we can all possible formal things
in some sense exist
and therefore it is a necessary feature
of the perception of a thing embedded
within
within this sort of set of all possible
formal things that you'll get something
which is like ordinary physics
now one consequence of this which again
i maybe i shouldn't go into
uh in more detail but but there's a
question does mathematics exist
in other words you write down you know
you might think mathematics oh it's just
a set of rules we can say
we're going to choose to make it be the
case that if x and y are numbers
x plus y equals y plus x and we have a
whole bunch of other rules
these are the so-called axioms of
mathematics and you can write down one
set of axioms you can write down another
set of axioms
you might say all mathematics is is the
working out of these
particular sets of axioms that we chose
and in that sense mathematics doesn't
really
exist it's just something where somebody
chose to wrote down these axioms
and so then you work out its
consequences one of the things that i
realized and i have to say it's only in
the last few weeks
is that um the that in a sense
if you imagine a generalized mathematics
a mathematics of all possible
mathematicses that
consists of in a sense thinking about
writing down all possible axiom systems
and looking at their consequences in
much the way same way that i described
looking at the consequences of all
possible rules for physics
if you look at that thing made of the
the consequences of all possible axiom
systems
that thing is again some elaborate
formal object
turns out it's the same elaborate formal
object
that is that thing for physics it is the
same working out of all possible formal
systems
that you have in physics so in a sense
if you say physics exists the universe
exists
it's a slice of this of this working out
of all possible rules
you have to say mathematics exists in
the same sense
because it too is a working out of all
possible uh
kind of mathematical rule all possible
formal rules
so then the question is just as we have
this notion of consciousness
our way of sampling the physical
universe what is the kind of
mathematical analog of that what is it
that a mathematician does that samples
this kind of
mathematical universe of all possible
mathematics is
and what is the what are the simplifying
features of a mathematical
consciousness which potentially drive
general laws of mathematics
and that's the that's the cliffhanger
that's where i am right now and thinking
about this stuff i haven't figured that
out
i'm kind of guessing that in what one
might call meta mathematical space the
space of all possible
mathematical theorems the space of all
possible results in mathematics
that there is an analog of things like
general relativity and an analog of
things like gravity in that space of all
possible mathematical theorems
where instead of there being atoms of
space that we can interpret as being
physical positions in space instead the
atoms of space
are like mathematical statements like
two plus two equals four for example
and um the uh and that that somehow
the the our sampling as mathematicians
or something
samples that space in in some way
that sort of reproduces the kinds of
things that we experience in human
mathematics
okay so a few other let me just i'll
cover a few other things there's so many
interesting questions here
there's a question here from prutz it's
often said that nothing can escape black
holes not even light
can gravitational waves escape black
holes the answer is kind of yes
um the it's a somewhat complicated thing
because
the description for example when two
black holes merge
they emit huge amounts of gravitational
radiation
and gravitational waves uh
yeah this is a little bit of a
complicated thing um
the basic answer is yes gravitational
waves
are sort of excluded uh black holes
okay outside a black hole okay any
matter like electrons atoms
tables chairs whatever the gravitational
effect of a black hole it'll pull those
things into the black hole
it'll pull them through the event
horizon and the event horizon is the
place where where nothing even light
uh the escape velocity is larger than
this than the speed of light
and nothing sort of escapes the event
horizon so all these things get pulled
inside the event horizon but one thing
so you might say so a black hole can
never sort of have an effect on things
because everything is pulled into the
event horizon the black hole
but there's an exception the black hole
does have a gravitational effect
because the black hole has this mass and
it it produces gravity and so
the gravitational field of a black hole
extends all the way out
you know it has an inverse square law or
whatever else but the gravitational
effect of a black hole there is a
distant gravitational effect of a black
hole
now gravitational waves are a
gravitational effect
and so they're kind of excluded from the
everything gets pulled into the black
hole
that they don't work the same way
because the ground the black hole does
have a gravitational effect the
black hole does have a um uh
an effect on on um on the outside world
through through gravity
in any case the that when you think
about this question about sort of things
getting pulled into a black hole there's
a lot of confusion there because
the a black hole in some sense
you start a black hole off you follow
the laws of physics
and you might say how does it end up
being the case that
you have a particular set of initial
conditions for the black hole
then the black hole forms everything's
pulled into the black hole
it's like everything's crunched up
together and all that information
associated with
what went into the black hole was all
lost somewhere and
by the way we know pretty pretty good
evidence that black holes evaporate
and eventually they as a result of
quantum effects
they evaporate again and the black hole
disappears eventually
so the question is the information that
went into the black hole
and sort of got crunched up inside the
black hole some
somehow it came out again at the end and
that's a rather mysterious thing
in our theory of physics it looks like
we understand how that works
and it has a very bizarre feature so let
me let me explain one thing
just sort of for fun with black holes so
if you're pulled into a black hole
you uh let's see you
you're the you as far as you're
concerned
time is passing you're you know you're
measuring time you
go through the event horizon you don't
even notice going through the event
horizon
because but the different what's
happening is that the time
of somebody who is far away from the
black hole
is now very different from your time so
what happens is
gravity slows down time whenever there's
a phenomenon called gravitational
redshift
whenever there is a strong gravitational
field time runs slower
and the and that's what's happening in a
black hole
as you as you're pulled in through this
event horizon effectively
time is running more and more slowly for
you and
in a sense to an observer outside
you i'm sorry time is running as time
runs for you but to an observer on the
outside
it looks as if time is slowing down for
you
so that means as you watch that table
falling into the black hole it will
freeze right at the event horizon as far
as somebody
far away from the black hole is
concerned they will never
that time for them that the time of the
as far as the table is concerned it's
just keeping going it's
falling through the event horizon but as
far as a distant observer is concerned
it will have a appear to have frozen at
the event horizon
so that phenomenon is um as far as space
time is concerned
there's time effectively stops there for
an outside observer
now let's see is this explainable so one
of the things that happens is
that in this information paradox with
black holes
the thing that happens is that oh boy
there's a
sorry there's one concept that uh see
this is this is what's difficult in
giving these explanations
is that each one of these things is
built on different
kinds of ideas and physics for example
and
the question is can you get to a
particular uh
result in the explanation without
running into some horrible
uh sort of sinkhole of some complicated
idea
that um that you have to kind of get
through the complicated idea here is
the idea of virtual particles and the
idea of spontaneous production
of particle antiparticle pairs in the
vacuum
but let's just say that for reasons of
of
of the way quantum field theory works
can all the time
in the vacuum you are having little
electron positron positron is the
anti-particle of the electron
there's for a very short time you're
producing a positron electron
and then they annihilate again it's as
if that didn't happen but actually it
does happen and that's happening
throughout space
in fact in our models of physics that
process
of the sort of the so-called vacuum
fluctuations
are ultimately what knit together the
structure of space but that's a feature
of our models that's not something
that you see in traditional bottom field
theory but in traditional quantum field
theory you do see this this formation of
very short-lived electron positron pair
they annihilate again
okay well so they happily just they they
come into existence they annihilate
again
very short amounts of time it's all good
nobody notices it
however if that process happened
right at the event horizon of a black
hole and
one member of the electron positron pair
fell into the black hole
and the other one didn't what would
happen is they wouldn't be able to
annihilate anymore because one of them
is
is sucked into the black hole and it's
no longer available to annihilate the
other particle
and so what that means is that's the
origin of this thing called hawking
radiation
where which is a emission of particles
from a black hole
it's it's essentially because there are
these vacuum fluctuations
and one part of the vacuum fluctuation
is pulled into the black hole
leaving the other one unable to sort of
annihilate again and disappear
so it's been sort of confusing how that
works um
the uh i'll just say just for fun and
it's a little bit more complicated to
explain
the um the question of what really
happened there
is partly a question of in quantum
mechanics there's sort of a question
of in quantum mechanics there are many
histories for the universe that develop
there aren't definite things that happen
there are many different histories
and we only know the probabilities for
different things to happen
so in the case of of this
uh black hole event horizon thing there
are different histories that develop
and one history says the thing falls
into the black hole another history says
it doesn't
it goes somewhere else there are all
these different histories now normally
when we observe the universe we succeed
in knitting together all those different
histories that's the process of
quantum measurement is what knits
together those different histories
and the in a sense it is the a feature
of our brains and so on
that we are able to take this sort of
branched quantum histories and the
reason which i've understood only very
recently
is that our brains are also branching
and so what we're doing is we're
a branching brain is observing a
branching universe
and it turns out that that allows you to
have the possibility of the branching
brain to perceive a definite thing as
happening
anyway at the at the edge of a black
hole
there's a thing we call the entanglement
horizon and at that entanglement horizon
the very bizarre thing that happens is
that
no brain can knit together those
different branches of history
in other words if if the brain was
trying to come to a conclusion
what actually happened here the brain
would never be able to do that it would
always say i don't know
there's this quantum branch and there's
that quantum branch i can't bring these
things together
in a sense you can say it can't form a
classical thought a definitive thought
it's always the the branches the
different branches of history of the
brain
are not able to be merged together to
conclude that something definite
happened and that's that's more or less
that's the weird effect
that we think happens uh at the edge of
a black hole
um
well anyway the the uh oh my gosh
the you guys are very very active today
um i'll try and just address a few more
of these i
this is a holiday day today so i'm i'm
uh
i'm able to spend a bit more time on
this um
the uh
let's see there's a question from cast
here
how could we be reliable judges of what
is metaphysically possible
rather than what seems possible to us
given our current evidence
epistemic possibility how could we get
evidence about which formal systems are
metaphysically possible
to be realized
boy okay this was you guys
are asking me to do serious real-time
philosophy here
okay um let me let me take a little bit
of a crack at that it might get a little
complicated
so
let's see um
this question about what is in principle
possible what is formally possible
versus what we know to actually be
possible by doing experiments
ah this is this is going to get us into
some um well
okay the surprising fact
about what is formerly possible
is is the following thing and it's
related to the idea of universal
computation
so you might think that
given certain rules by which a thing
operates
there would be it would be able to do
certain things based on those rules
and nothing other than the things that
it was set up to do according to its
rules
you know you have an adding machine all
it does is add you have a multiplying
machine all it does is multiply
okay the surprising fact is that there
exists
universal computers computers where
given a fixed hardware a fixed set of
instructions for the computer
it's possible to make software it's
possible to
set up the initial conditions for the
computer
to make the computer do anything to make
it run
any program you can imagine running so
you might think
you've got a computer it has a
particular set of instructions in its
hardware
it can only do particular things but no
when looked at in terms of the programs
it can run
those programs can it can do anything
with
in those programs can do anything in
other words you could say how does the
computer run
the video conferencing software i'm
running right now
well in the end it's running it in terms
of machine instructions etc etc etc
a different computer can run the very
same video conferencing
can achieve the same functionality for
video conferencing in other words
from a fixed set of primitives you can
achieve
different sets of primitives different
universal sets of primitives
can achieve all the same kinds of things
so it's not the case that
you're kind of locked in these islands
of one set of one sort of set of
possible rules does one kind of thing
another set of rules does another kind
of thing once you have these rules that
are computationally universal
any one of them can be used to construct
a thing that does anything that can be
done and so i think that that's
that's an important thing to realize in
terms of understanding
what is sort of metaphysically possible
versus um
uh versus what um um
the uh um versus the uh
um um what am i saying but
versus some uh in other words
given a universal system anything is
possible in some sense
it will be implemented differently in
different universal systems
but in terms of the way that for example
it will be perceived
it will be the same so i think that's
that's part of the sort of philosophical
untangling
of this question all right maybe a
couple more things here and then um
oh gosh there's a there's a point here
hello
asks implications of hyper computation
so the thing i just described about
universal computers
um there is a set of computations that
can be done by
a what we currently think of as a
universal computer
the formal version is things like
touring machines but it can be just a
practical computer
that has its particular instructions you
can write programs that do a whole range
of things
okay but imagine there's a thing that
no existing computer can do in a finite
amount of time
there are things where you could say ask
questions like what will be the infinite
time results of this thing
and you can prove that no computer can
answer that question
in a finite amount of time would take
any of our existing computers an
infinite amount of time to answer that
question
well let's imagine just as a thought
experiment let's imagine
we had a black box that just answers
those questions it's usually called an
oracle in the theory of computation
um it's kind of a bad name in terms of
the classical use of the term oracle but
never
never mind that it's not like the
delphic article but it's a it's another
kind of article where you're
where you're saying in a sense this
computation that for any computer that
we know how to build
would take an infinite time but we've
got a black box that just tells us up
the answer is this
so imagine we have such a black box
that's what hyper computation is
is the idea that we could have such
black boxes that jump ahead and answer
what would otherwise be infinite
computational questions can be answered
in finite time
and so then the question is what does it
mean if there is
hypercomputation so one thing is in our
theory of physics
one of the definitive things that our
theory of physics says is
hyper computation is impossible in our
universe so
it's that's not a it's not an obvious
fact it's not something derivable
it's essentially claimed to be a law of
nature that hyper computation is
impossible in our universe
actually we can go a little further than
that it's actually a little bit more
bizarre
in this theory where the universe runs
according to all possible rules
you say well why don't you throw a hyper
computation rule in there as well
in addition to all these ordinary
computational rules throw in a
hyper-computational rule
and say you know what happens then okay
what happens is kind of bizarre
what happens is for any observer
that's like us anything embedded in this
universe
that's made of stuff that isn't
hyper-computational
there will be everything
hyper-computational
will be separated by an event horizon
from everything that isn't
so in other words assuming that we're
not hyper computational already
then everything about if there was
hypercomputation in the universe
we would never be able to tell that it
was there because
it would be as if it was on the other
side of a black hole event horizon from
us
um and it would sort of separate out
from the rest of the universe
the pieces that a hyper computational
would separate out
so in that sense and in fact one reason
that happens is
because time progresses for us and the
rest of the universe it just chugs along
and
you know as as time goes on all these
computations are happening that's kind
of what the experience of time is
is all these computations happening but
let's imagine we have this
hyper-computational thing
over here it says oh you're wasting all
your time
so to speak doing all these computations
to figure out what's going to happen
i the hyper-computational thing i can
just jump ahead
for me time your in your time
has basically is nothing for me it's as
if your time has stopped for me
and that's essentially exactly the same
kind of thing that happens in black
holes
so in a sense if there is
hypercomputation uh
our models of physics say in the part of
the universe
accessible to us everything accessible
to us is only computation
and not hyper computation and even we
think we can derive
formally that if there is
hypercomputation it must be separated
from us
in the structure of our models of
physics so it's kind of a prediction of
our models of physics
um
so let's see maybe maybe one or two
other things here um
uh
well gcep is asking what's what was the
last crazy or unrealistic but
interesting thought
with regard to science or reality a
speculation that isn't based in any
research but as an intuition
um yeah well i've been having a bunch of
those very recently actually
it's um i think
that what i've realized is that the
fundamental theory of physics is the
same as the fundamental theory of
mathematics
and that in a sense and something people
have been working on our physics project
particularly a person called jonathan
gorad and i have been talking about this
for
for about a year but it's sort of become
clearer to me
that um uh you know how this really
potentially works
and um uh
i think well let's see um
kind of describing
well okay so so one thing uh maybe this
is too too too complicated but
but um uh
one thing that's always interesting to
me is
what you know science has gone in
certain directions
has built up certain theories and many
things are built on top of those
scientific theories once you have a
scientific theory
and it's well developed it makes sense
to leverage that theory and just build
more and more and more stuff on top of
that theory
and so it's happened in many areas like
in the foundations of mathematics that's
happened
i have a strong suspicion that that the
direction that's been taken for the last
hundred years is probably wrong
and that that the um that the way people
have tried to base mathematics on
individual axiom systems just isn't the
right way to think about it
and actually plato back a very long time
ago had kind of a
more holistic view of mathematics that
i'm kind of suspecting is correct
um and uh and that we can actually that
that
view of mathematics is going to allow us
to derive
some very general meta-mathematical
facts
um that uh uh go go that is sort of a
a different level of mathematical
thinking that we've been able to have so
far
anyway that's a that's just a um uh
um it's just a a thought there there's a
whole bunch related to that
but uh dylan asks if a piece of space
breaks off
does it just float around in the
universe well you see the problem is it
isn't in the universe
it space it is breaking off from space
it is a separate piece of space that is
not in any way connected
to the space that we know about so it is
just
separate it's like saying if you lived
on the surface of the earth
and you know the moon broke off from the
earth and you were creatures now living
on the surface of the moon
uh there isn't a sense in which you know
your your
your world is the surface of the moon
now separate from the surface of the
earth
and it's the same kind of thing here
it's a it's a separate piece of space
and it has no interaction whatsoever it
has
absolutely no connection to existing
space so all the little rules that are
running in it
they're all running within that region
of space now if you really want to get
complicated about it
in this idea of multiple histories that
happens in quantum mechanics
it's an interesting question as this
piece breaks off does it break off in
all possible histories
or how does it work how does the bundle
of histories that break off
relate to the piece of space that's
breaking off and i suspect
that there is a sense in which um let me
see
that's an interesting question hmm okay
i have not thought about this properly
that there's a there's this notion of
ordinary space
which is the sort of connection of all
these atoms of space together
there's a notion of what we call
branchial space the space of possible
branches
of history and that too is a space of
different possible things that can
happen in history and it's a
it's a branchial space since the one in
which quantum mechanics plays out
and so a good question oh yes actually i
did figure this out
yeah um is the question of whether
there are what happens with respect to
this branchial space
when a piece of the universe bakes off
and i think what happens there's sort of
a formal idea in quantum mechanics
uh things called super selection rules
that i think is what happens there and i
think what will happen is
that essentially no observer could ever
will ever conclude yes that
the observer can never put together the
thing which is in the broken off piece
of the universe
with the thing which is in the unbroken
off piece they can never be sort of
thought about together
there are always things which are for
any observer they're always
they'll be observers in the broken off
piece and there'll be observers in the
non-broken off piece
and no observer could ever straddle the
difference
those two pieces so it's as if they
really really are separate and they they
just don't don't relate to each other
um
uh if a piece of the universe detaches
in a supercritical black hole
is that universe is the universe
contained in the piece that breaks off
so subject to hawking radiation
um let me think about that for a second
um
i think the answer is okay here's the
answer i think
walking radiation is something that
happens when you have a black
you have space that's kind of all of
space and somewhere in space is this
black hole with a little event horizon
and you're looking at what happens
outside of the black hole
when a piece breaks off i think the
piece that breaks off
is its own whole universe there's no
outside to it
so there's no sense in which you can
have radiation
that goes from from the from the thing
to the outside of the thing there is no
outside it's just
that's it the thing that broke off is
the whole universe is the whole sort of
sort of separated universe and so there
isn't a place in which radiation can
occur
um
and uh stanio is asking was the universe
created from an explosion
from a super super super black hole well
in some sense yes i mean
in in some sense the universe even in
the standard models of cosmology is sort
of like a white hole
it's sort of like a thing from which uh
you start off from from the singularity
that you can't explain
and then all this stuff is coming out
from that singularity it's sort of that
same
that same kind of idea so yes in some
mathematical sense that's right
i'm not sure that that's a good way to
think about it my way of thinking about
it tends to be the universe starts as
this infinite dimensional thing
that where everything is connected to
everything and gradually
that sort of as things unfold that
becomes something that is more like our
three-dimensional space i think that's a
better way to think about it
rather than a traditional way of
thinking about black holes and so on
which is something that already lives in
three-dimensional
space um
okay there's andrew von is asking in
this close critical black holes we see a
handful of threads that connect our
universe
in an actual microscope you see a
structure against a black background
what's the background here
well there isn't one um the best you
would see
is and when i say c it's very much in
quotation marks
the way you would detect this is the
following in
if you have something i don't know you
have a
uh a bunch of um sand grains
that are going through some some you
know that they're going through a tube
or something
you've got enough sand grains it seems
like it's just a continuous flow of sand
but let's say you make the tube very
very very narrow eventually the tube is
narrow enough
that individual grains go through the
tube and you can tell
if you're measuring how much mass is
going through the tube
usually it'll just be oh there's a whole
bunch of mass going through and doesn't
change very much from
one moment in time to another because
they're just you know there are there
might be a million sand grains or a
million and one that's not very
different
but by the time you're down to this very
thin tube and it's like well
one sand grain went through or no sand
grains went through at that moment
then it's a different kind of thing and
you can tell
that it's kind of like there's this
there's this you can you can sort of
hear the fact though not here i mean
again i'm using analogies here
um you can sort of tell oh just one sand
grain went through or
no sand grains went through in that
moment it's the same kind of thing
it's usually called shot noise and it's
kind of
like if you imagine uh i don't know if
you imagine raindrops falling on
a roof or something and um you know
there are lots and lots of raindrops
you'll just have this continuous
kind of hissing sound or something but
as it gets down to individual raindrops
you'll start hearing the individual
raindrops and it's the same kind of
thing here that you might be able to see
effects that don't seem like they're
they're smooth continuous effects that
are unchanged with time
but more you'll actually detect those
random fluctuations
it's a little bit the same way that
brownian motion was detected when people
discovered molecules
back in the 1830s maybe
1850s perhaps one of the things that was
done
was you put a pollen grain in water
pollen grain is light enough
that when it's kicked by individual
molecules of water hitting it
it moves and so instead of the pollen
grain just so smoothly moving around
it's light enough it's small enough that
it's sensitive to individual buffeting
by individual molecules
and so you can kind of tell that there
are individual discrete molecules there
and that's the kind of thing one might
expect with these uh with these black
holes where things are
potentially breaking off um all right we
should probably uh
much as there are lots of interesting
questions about lots of different things
um
let's see there's a question from gcep
could black holes be a pinch in space
where it goes inside out actually the
traditional theory of general relativity
in rotating black holes so-called curb
like holes
something very much like that happens
it's believed that
that would never actually be observed
and it's inside event horizons which
means that no outside observer could
observe it
but mathematically that's something very
much like that things sort of turn
themselves inside out from black holes
to white holes
and so on it's rather bizarre um it
isn't quite as bizarre in our models of
space-time
in a sense people would say well who
cares because it's all inside an event
horizon
but in our models we can actually obs we
can actually tell what happens inside
there
and um well it isn't as bizarre the most
bizarre thing happened that seems to
happen
is that pieces can potentially break off
by the way someone asked about
perhaps somebody asked about about
gravitational radiation in black holes
one of the effects that i think as a
consequence of our models is the thing
that i call black hole wind
so i think there is a uh
there's a there will be a small amount
of gravitational radiation
that we sort of emitted from black holes
as a necessary feature of the discrete
structure of space
whether it's large enough to be
detectable i don't know but it's an
interesting
effect um and uh
um oh pritz is asking black holes rotate
at critical speed
could it expose hyper computation i
don't think so i don't think so i think
the thing i think
these pieces just break off i think that
the question of whether
yes in our models the passage of time
is a consequence of computational
processes occurring
and so hyper computation requires that
you infinitely speed up the passage of
time
and that's not something you can do
within our models
so uh
anyways there's a um um uh there's a
question here about uh i really need to
wrap up but there's a i'm just um
um um the question here from zebsby
are there plans to somehow incorporate
formal method tooling i think
i think what formal methods means is
sort of you've got a computer program
but you make essentially a mathematical
proof about what the computer program
does
and um in fact yes in our
in our explorations of theory of physics
we're making use of a whole bunch of
those kinds of techniques
in fact to make it even more bizarre the
the actual
evolution of these different paths and
quantum mechanics
can be thought of as being like possible
proofs
in other words to a proof is showing
these two things are equal
we've got certain certain relations that
we can use in mathematics can we piece
these together
to get from one thing to another to show
that these two things are equal
that turns out to be something like
finding these pods and quantum mechanics
and we've actually done a bunch of work
on on using that in a practical way
all right i should uh wrap up here and
for those in the in the us
um uh happy holiday weekend
and for other people i look forward to
doing this again same time next week
thanks very much